It seems that our planet has become more interdependent than ever,
But loneliness is twice that of America since the 1980s, with more than 40 percent of adults feeling so.
So, should you worry if you feel the same thing? Can the unit kill you?
Unity is a psychological technique designed to motivate you to seek social interactions,
But largely subjective.
In other words, if you feel lonely, then you are alone.
This does not necessarily mean you are isolated, or you do not have friends;
It just means that those social interactions that are necessary for you have not materialized.
We often think of loneliness as something to the elderly,
But a recent study found that young people between the ages of 16 and 24 were more affected than any other group.
In one of the most painful studies, scientists have discovered that being lonely makes cold symptoms worse.
Hundreds of healthy people tested isolation measure,
They were then given nasal passages containing the common cold virus.
(Ugh)
At this stage, those who were sick with the disease were isolated in five-day hotel rooms,
Those who reported feeling lonely before taking the test were also reported to have worse cold symptoms.
Have you ever noticed that food tastes better when you are hungry?
Scientists have already seen the same phenomenon with unity.
When those participants were connected to MRI devices and showed the image of one of their loved ones and the image of a stranger
Those who scored high results in the UCLA unit gauge test
Showed a greater reaction in the reward system in the brain when they saw the image of one of their loved ones,
While those who did not have a high sense of loneliness showed a similar response between a loved one and a stranger.
This helps us to know that this does not mean that these individuals lack close relationships,
It means that they yearn to promote that social interaction.
Chronic loneliness can also change your body at the cellular level. Research has concluded that
People who feel lonely have 209 different gene expressions in some of their white blood cells
Including increased activity of inflammatory agents.
Now, inflammation is an important response to injuries,
But chronic inflammation destroys your body.
As a result, we see weak social relations
There is a 29% increase in coronary heart disease
An increase of 32% for stroke.
In general, people with strong social relationships have a 50% greater chance of survival overall.
This means they are less likely to die during the same time period.
Making loneliness a deadly risk, such as a 15-cigarette drink a day, lack of exercise, or obesity.
So, yes, loneliness can increase your chances of dying.
The growing number of people who feel lonely may be due to changes in our culture.
Global capitalism and its focus on the individual has changed our ability to have strong social ties.
If you feel lonely, know that you are not alone.
This is usually not a reflection of whether you are loved or not, and there is a small step you can take today to feel more connected:
Try to make visual communication more profound, both with those people you know, or even a passerby on the street.
Studies have shown that visual communication is a movement that makes both parties involved
Feel more connected with humanity.
[If you have not learned yet, we have launched Greg and Mitch.]
[We have made a complete transformation for the first time.]
[If you want to see this really great video, you can see it here.]
[We also started a weekly radio program called "Side Note" to be broadcast every Wednesday]
[In which we discuss controversial topics, and then navigate through everything related to science through it.]
[So we'll leave you the link in the video description.]
[Do not forget to subscribe to our channel, and hope to see you next Thursday and a new scientific video, to meet!]